professor in GCI and she's also a filly
with Amazon at the moment and she has
done lots of amazing work using tensor
spectral method for probabilistic
graphical models but now all this talk
is she's going to talk about a
distributor deep learning Thank You Lee
and you don't find looked at the series
of talks in this workshop I think this
will be the most practical talk you'll
hear so you know I hope this is a
different perspective in terms of when
we say computational aspects of machine
learning a big aspect is how do we
actually you know enable these
computations at scale you know the
infrastructure support the software
support and running you know being able
to quickly develop such you know take
the algorithms and productionize it so
I'll discuss more on you know the
practical side of such aspects and also
described how MX net is a very
compelling package to use for
distributed deep learning at scale so
we're all very excited about the
developments and machine learning and
artificial intelligence right but if you
really think about what are some of the
crucial ingredients that enable this
revolution its many other things in
addition to the core algorithms right so
an important part of it was having very
robust software packages you know it's
the software support that enabled people
to quickly innovate and try out
algorithms at scale and indeed the
compute power right so in a sense most
of the algorithms have been around for
decades but what changed the equation
now was being able to do it at scales
that were not possible even five years
ago in some cases and of course the
third important component was creation
of data so having access to large open
source datasets
data sets right enabled us to really
push the boundaries of what's possible
in machine learning and and the question
today is like how we can have such an
ecosystem where we are actively enabling
algorithm writers to easily launch their
us I know software at scale and so when
it comes to deploying any of these deep
learning models right so they are
enormous so this is I think the
inception v3 Network one of the
state-of-art
networks and indeed you would not be
thinking about programming this from
scratch so we need like enough set of
primitives and enough software support
to enable such an operation and the
other thing is they the number of
computations even for one image to go
through this network is enormous right
so you need billions of computations for
each image so how to enable this is you
know important and this is where the
question of what hardware to use is also
comes into play and GPUs have been very
successful because they provide much
more flops compared to the comparable
CPU and so it's the framework of choice
for deep learning and now we are seeing
growth in the Asics or you know much
more dedicated hardware for these deep
learning so if we want to now go to the
next level in terms of scaling up deep
learning a hardware and architecture
becomes an important consideration as
well right so the other consideration is
memory so as we have bigger and bigger
models how do we enable this and it's so
and we could all at the same time we
want to do this on smaller devices you
know we can do this on your smartphone
you can have IOT devices right the
Raspberry Pi
so you know there Sherman we have large
strong memory constraints how do we
still get state of art results or
accurate results with that so if you
naively do the computations the memory
consumption will grow linearly as you
add more and more layers and the state
of the art networks have hundreds of
layers right so the question of how to
easily program such large networks how
do we do computations at scale and how
do we worry about memory consumption I
see these as three important aspects
when it comes to deploying deep learning
yeah so when it comes to our software
package today there is a whole host of
choices so how do we judge in terms of
having some desirable attributes to run
deep learning at scale so as I said the
first consideration is program ability
right so whether there is software
support in terms of enough set of
primitives which simplify defining the
networks which simplify the optimization
procedures and which provide us flexible
programming environment to for people to
you know be able to optimize for
computation and memory right so program
ability is an important consideration
the second one is portability so as I
said today we have a whole host of
choices when it comes to different
platforms where we want to run our
machine learning algorithm and the more
portable the code is it's just easier to
you know just try try it across a
different set of platforms and this is
where the ability to also adapt to
different memory requirements will be
useful the third one is efficiency right
so as researchers in machine learning we
so far haven't been paying much
attention to this part because you know
if thinking of computation as something
that's out there
that'll solve our problems but if as we
scale up the computations more and more
efficiency becomes important because we
just can't you know keep having a
hundred more or thousand more GPUs right
so our tasks are getting more complex
the models are getting bigger so
efficiency will give us a big win over
time and that Amazon we are enabling
machine learning applications on the
cloud infrastructure and so there is a
huge motivation for having efficient
packages because that would also result
in a huge reduction in costs for the
customer running this on the cloud and
so we want to worry about efficiency
both during training got at inference
so as I said there is a whole host of
choices for our deep learning software
and I think that's a good thing
my dargah bleah that has also led for
research to really take off right the
availability of a whole host of software
so what we are doing that the AWS deep
learning group is actively developing on
MX net and supporting MX net extensively
on the AWS infrastructure so we say that
it's a framework of choice for us and
what we recommend to our customers and
there are two important justifications
for that so one is that this is the most
open source software or of all right so
we have the Apache open source
certification and we have an active
ecosystem of developers outside of
Amazon in fact it started out as
University projects so some of the key
contributors muli who was a student at
CMU is now at Amazon T and chi-chan was
at u-dub you know there's kind of a lot
of university effort that went into
building MX net and now as I said the
second aspect is we are actively
ensuring that it integrates well with
the AWS infrastructure and gives very
efficient scaling for many of the deep
learning applications so let us now see
like what I'm Xing it offers in terms of
program ability right so if you think of
programming models there are mainly two
types right so okay before the models so
there is first the choice of languages
right so there's a whole host of five
programming languages depending on your
background you may prefer one or the
other so I think for a lot of data
scientists probably Python is the top
choice right may be followed are maybe
the choice for statisticians in a MATLAB
for some others
so you have the whole host of choices
when it comes to the front end but the
problem is the performance varies if you
just run these frameworks as it is so
what a mixed net offers is take any of
these friends and languages and through
a C++ interface you can connect it to
efficient back in libraries it could be
the CUDA deep learning libraries or the
mkl libraries for the CPU alright so
that's the idea that your language of
choice should not matter for the end
performance and so you have the whole
choice of languages that you can use to
program you know you can also use
scholar if your spark background now you
can also integrate your spark jobs with
a mix net in this manner alright so the
next part is the programming model that
I was talking about so they're mainly
two forms right so the simple one is the
imperative style of programming you know
this is the simple Python code here so
you just interpret this line by line
right so there's no compilation process
this is easy to write it's easy to debug
right but of course the downside is this
is bad for optimization right so you
especially in a parallel system if you
want to run this code optimally you want
to think about optimal memory
allocations and so on there is no way to
do it with imperative programming as it
is and so you know the simplest like if
you think about MATLAB Python they have
the imperative style of programming but
that's why it's also very bad for
performance right so imperative style
just by itself is not good for
performance so the other approach is the
declarative style of programming right
so here what you do is you declare all
the variables and you compile this
program to get a computation graph and
because of this computation graph then
there is knowledge about how you can
optimize for us a memory and
computations in this simple example here
you know that you know this you have
this variable C and then it's
overwritten in the very next step right
so you don't need a separate piece of
memory for both C and D so you can you
know replace the memory of C with D
later so you can plan out the memory
allocations better because you have this
computation graph and that's why like
the many of the state of art deep
learning packages have the declarative
style of programming because that not
then you can have better performance
using that but of course the downside is
that this is more involved to write
compared to the imperative style right
and it's also leads to much longer
programs and so on and so so what do we
have in MX net
so what MX net does is it helps you mix
both the styles of programming so MX net
has this ndra API so this is nothing but
a multi-dimensional array right so you
can declare this in the imperative style
and do all you know any set of
operations using imperative programming
and then you can import that into your
symbolic executor during the process
right so the idea is you can have parts
of the computation that are not very
important for optimization right for
optimization of memory in the imperative
style and then you can bring that into
your symbolic executor right so here in
this example the network architecture is
written out in this side symbolic manner
right and intuitively it's the
architecture that matters a lot for
performance because like how the network
is what the forward and backward passes
are right that's important to optimize
for but if it is maybe some operations
on the array
it may be a say the gradient step right
that can be written in the imperative
style so you can mix these two paradigms
of programming together in MX net so you
can also do the opposite you can have
your modules written in declarative
style and then bring that into your
imperative programming so in this
example here you're bringing in this
module that was written in symbolic
style and then you're doing this
parameter update right in the imperative
style and this leads to much shorter
programs compared to writing everything
in the declarative sense right so that's
the idea that MX net gives the developer
the flexibility to decide you know when
do we need in imperative programming and
when do we need a symbolic execution and
so depending on where you you know
getting the computation graph is
essential for doing many efficient
memory allocations and so on there you
write it in declarative style in other
parts of the execution you write it in
symbolic in imperative style right so
this gives you the most flexible
programming framework out of all the
deep learning packages so let us now see
how MX net makes it easy to polt across
different platforms so the idea is you
can fit all the core libraries all the
dependencies into a single source file
and so you can easily port from one
platform to the other so can compile in
any platform
so this was a simple smartphone app for
come you know recognizing objects and it
was done in a pretty straightforward
manner using MX Net on JavaScript so
because of the JavaScript support you
can easily now run applications on your
smart phone all right so so this is
another thing that I mix in it supports
that makes it easy to port applications
into device different architectures so
the other thing that I described that is
important is memory optimization right
so if we as we have our models growing
bigger and bigger right so one option is
to keep growing also our hardware right
but there are limits and model
parallelism across different machines is
still quite challenging so are there
ways to you know still train big models
but do more intelligent memory
allocation right so this is the
computation graph for the standard
backward forward and backward pass right
so your going forward in the network
sorry this is a typo and then you share
the information about the activations in
each layer here right and then you go
backwards so the input is here right so
you start here and in the forward pass
you are just computing the activations
in each layer and during the backward
pass you are updating the weights of
each layer right and for that you need
information about the activation in that
layer so use that and then you update
the weights so this is the standard
computation graph and if you were to
just allocate memory for each layer you
would have linear requirement of memory
right so if you stored all the
activations in this forward pass you
would require memory that's linear in
the number of layers so what are some
other things you can do instead so one
option is not to store everything but to
recompute to as needed
right so in they are in this example
here what we did was just divide this
into two segments and we'll only store
the head node in the segment right so
the activations that are computed here
we won't be storing in the memory so now
the memory requirement is much more
reduced because I'm only storing these
head nodes and so what then needs to be
done is during the backward pass you
recompute the results right so now as I
need the information about this
activation here I would be recomputing
it on the fly
and then going go further and so now the
question is there is this trade-off
between you know the computation and
memory that you can play so you can say
like how many times do I recompute this
versus store everything in memory right
so depending on the memory you know
space that I have I can play this game
so the one interesting question is also
what to store here right so if you think
about just storing say the first few
activations here that's not very
effective right because you would have
to like to compute this activation here
you would have to run through all of
this so that's where it's more useful to
segment them into parts so that way you
can start with this head node and only
start computing from that point onwards
and so with this you can show that the
memory requirement can be reduced to as
much a square root of the number of
layers while just requiring in total an
extra forward pass
all right that's because like in each
segment here you only like start from
the head node of that segment and the
proceed a few steps until you need to
recompute the activation needed and yeah
so this way you can now get a sub linear
memory requirement for your networks
without doing any compression right so
you're at the end of the day still
getting exactly the same results as you
would in a fully in the complete memory
model
but now you can run this with the sub
linear memory and so there's lots of
interesting questions here on how to
trade-off memory and computation and MX
Net enables you to you know play with
these trade-offs pretty easily and so
this is the paper if you want to like
learn about more details how much memory
you need so I had some numbers here
right so just to see like how much we
can reduce memory so the ResNet like
thousand layers right so bad size 32 so
if you want to store like the
activations of the entire batch right so
each forward pass you take the
activations of the whole batch and you
do this four thousand layers that's
about 130 GB if you were to store all of
that and now only for storing this you
know the head nodes you would see a big
reduction in this memory and same like
LS TMS right so you can now you know
think about different schemes the
trade-off computation and memory are
using this framework and so that way you
can outrun this even on smaller devices
or enable larger models with more layers
but not incur a huge memory cost
yeah so now the third aspect is
performance like how do we ensure good
performance even as we scale up to
hundreds of GPUs right so the always the
challenges there's a lot of overhead
when it comes to the control layer when
it comes to how do we you know get the
data to these GPUs what's the
communication cost in Walled you know in
them come you know putting together the
results so I'll show you some benchmarks
on how MX Net performs on different
measures and indeed you know this aspect
of optimizing for parallel programs is a
very classical problem right but why we
need new frameworks now is that the
network's have gotten very complex so
just looking at having two GPUs and a
CPU and looking at all the forward and
backward pass computations right it's it
gets very messy so there is MPI but MPI
is just too low-level r2 enables
parallelizing deep learning applications
so we really don't want to worry about
the low-level details of each you know
computation with which device to send it
to when to get the result back and so on
so how MX net paralyzes is based on the
philosophy of hierarchical parameter
server right so the lowest levels loved
ones are the workers so the GPUs in this
case since if you are running on GPUs
the GPUs are the workers and so if this
is the data parallelism model where each
part of the data goes to each GPU so
they have local updates of their
gradients and then there is a level one
server which is one of the GPUs and so
that takes in the gradient updates right
combines them together sends it back to
the workers and this continues
and so the idea is most of the
communication happens just within the
GPUs and this can be done through the
high bandwidth PCIe switch and so this
is much faster than you know going to
the CPU or for that matter going all the
way to the networking back so you try to
minimize the communication to the higher
levels as much as possible and most of
these iterative operations are happening
at the level of just gpo to GPU
communication and that's faster so you
can think about scalability right at
multiple levels one is within a single
GPU there are lots of course so how do
you scale across the course right plan
so the next level is across multiple
GPUs on the same machine so the largest
one we have on AWS has up to 16 GPUs the
K ATS and this is the P to 16x large
instance and of course you can take lots
of such nodes together and parallel eyes
across them as well yeah and we have the
benchmarks on github so you can go and
verify this yourself there
and so what we see is on a single
instance of P - 16 X large with 16 GPUs
you get about 91% efficiency for the
state of art networks right the
resonator and the inception v3 you get
very high efficiency so the ideal is of
course as you double the GPUs your
throughput also doubles and you can see
that we are getting quite close to that
so the next level of scaling is then to
ask what about multiple such instances
so here we took 16 instances of Pedro
16x large and that's like 256 GPUs and
we do see some drop in efficiency but
not a whole lot right so as I said on
the github repository you will see a lot
of details but just to mention a few
this was done on the image net and you
cannot here the inception and the rest
net the batch size is quite small it
should the curve looks like a
superlinear why not yes you
more machines we cannot get to go yes
the ideal is linear right so we are
below that I mean this is like this is
doubling here yeah yeah yeah so this is
the the scale is yeah yeah it's not a
linear scale yeah
it's strict but yeah so that's I know
it's one thing to notice you can also
have this on small batch sizes you know
like you can get to much better
efficiency on large batch sizes but
that's bad for generalization right so
you don't want too large a bad size and
doing this one smaller batch sizes is
the challenge and and we're doing good
even there yeah so that's the idea that
you get this high efficiency even as you
scale up to hundreds of GPUs so if you
want to run these systems continuously
Amex net is a very strong candidate for
that yeah measured based on the bad
sense or is it what is the so I think
the so this one is like the number of
images per second that and yeah but this
is a bad size we feed in writes
so we have an ambitious roadmap to grow
Amex net to encompass even other aspects
of machine learning you know to offer
more machine learning algorithms under
this platform and in terms of like
ongoing work I would say an important
addition that will be soon available is
sparse data types you know the current
deep learning mostly requires only dense
operations but if you want to think
about other applications or even think
about schemes that compress the
activations in different layers you need
sparse support right and that's an
important addition we are doing and the
other part that's you know closer to my
research right has been in terms of how
to enable tensor operations at scale so
what I'll show is some preliminary
results in you know looking at neural
network architectures and enabling
tensor operations and leading this
leading to better performance so the
idea is indeed tensors are the right
framework to think about
multi-dimensional data right so we have
now many different many multiple
channels that go into a neural network
for instance you know at the input layer
that is the width height and the
channels right which is RGB the input
layer and as you go through the
activation layers you have these number
of filters so it's variable number of
channels so what you really have is
tensors that are being processed in each
layer of the network but we're really
not thinking of them as tensors but as
matrices and so the question is by you
know learning weights that operate
directly on the tensor can we get a good
better accuracy or you know model with
fewer parameters that does equally well
or almost the same amount so that's the
idea that can we
now enable these tensor contraction
layers into our neural network models so
this is the popular Aleks net model
right so we have a whole set of
convolutional layers right so
convolution fooling and so on and then
at the end of it there are all these
densely connected layers and these are
always the most expensive ones because
they have a whole lot of parameters here
and so now the question is in these
densely connected layers we are taking
these tensors flattening them into
matrices and you know learning the
weights can we now change that and learn
tensor weights that contract the tensor
directly right so this is the classic
the usual Alyx net so you go from input
and then after many convolution and
pooling layers you get a tensor here you
flatten it and feed it to the fully
connected layer and instead what we'll
do is we'll do tensor contraction and
then see how that changes the result and
so this is the intuition that if you you
know have this tensor you you know want
to really think of a contraction in all
the dimensions simultaneously right so
can we now directly learn the
contractions that would result in a low
rank tensor and so this is the layer so
I mean don't worry about the details
here but the main intuition is you know
if you have this tensor you want to
learn the weights that contract in each
of the dimensions and so we are just
like kind of you know transfer like
transposing the tensor and just learning
the weights in each for each dimension
and so just a preliminary results what
we see is you know the best cases you
get a now almost 44 percent savings in
terms of the parameters in these dense
layers and in fact even a better
accuracy compared to the baseline right
so the idea is because now you're
exploiting the multi
dimensional structure in your chancer
coming from the convolution layers you
can get now better accuracy with fewer
parameters and indeed this is just the
preliminary result I see that there can
be use of tensors in a whole lot of
different neural network architectures
so this is a I think an interesting
direction that I hope to have more
results on near future
any questions
this one's our top top one dangerous yes
your top one yeah that's the harder one
right so we wanted to him for that
yes so now in the remaining 10 minutes I
want to give you an overview how at AWS
we are you know enabling you to quickly
launch deep learning jobs and be able to
kind of not worry about setting up the
infrastructure say updating the
libraries like kind of this er you know
all these are mundane details but they
take up a lot of time from the data
scientists and so one of the you know
aspects is this deep learning army army
stands for Amazon machine images so
these are pre-configured to quickly get
you started with deep learning and as I
said the other aspect is enabling GPU
instances so the p2 instances are the
powerful ones and so you can get lots of
GPUs if you like to do your deep
learning right so just to give you a
sense of how AWS is enabling
computations that are very large-scale
the experiments that we ran with 16 p2
16 X large instances is about 1.1 peda
flops right and the world's fastest
supercomputer I think it's in China is
about 93 para flops so we can get very
close to even the world's fastest
supercomputer by you know going through
the cloud infrastructure and there is
you know if we have to really scale up
machine learning even further right the
cloud I think is the answer to a lot of
the problems
and so the other aspect as I said is the
Army's so with this deep learning army
what you can have is all the packages
are up-to-date compiles right so it's
not just a mechs not any package the
choice that you have it's all like
maintained for you so you don't have to
worry about updating you know your build
breaking down and so on the drivers
everything's pre-installed so this is
like a one-stop shop where you can
quickly start your doing deep learning
rather than worrying about setting up
your infrastructure so I just had a very
quick video of how it's just a few
clicks to get you deep learning started
on AWS right it will just take a couple
of minutes you don't have to worry about
all the details but it's just to show
you that how easy the process is right
so you start from your ec2 console and
you create a stack and you know so as I
said there's the cloud formation script
you can take from one of the existing
scripts and and then after that you
decide what kind of instance you want
right you want a p2 instance and you
know the details like how many workers
you need and what you like to name the
stack as you see this demo with Donna
bit earlier and yeah pretty much like
there are few things like you know
permission controls that you want and
that's pretty much it
now you created a stack for running your
deep learning and you can now track the
progress of whether this stack is being
created right so that's the details you
have all your details of the different
stacks on your console
right so you can now see that you know
it's tight as it's running so the
workers are already ready to now launch
the deep learning jobs and right so SSH
to the master instance and then you hear
we are launching from one of the MX net
repositories and that's it you have the
training going right so um anybody can
just very quickly as you saw get started
with running the jobs than worry about
setting up the infrastructure or setting
up the libraries and so yeah that was
just a very quick demo to show how far
you you know we make it easy for you to
you know worry more about the algorithms
than about the details of how to set up
the infrastructure and so in addition to
the MX net effort that we are doing in
the group in Amazonia we have a number
of other services as well so recognition
is more for doing production level image
recognition we have legs that is natural
language understanding so it helps
chatbot developers easily develop
interfaces to interact with the
customers and Poly's a real-time text to
speech so let me just very quickly run
through those so with recognition you
can get real-time ba recognition both
object recognition as well as face
detection so you know obviously as you
know this would be giving like different
category labels with different
confidence levels right and we can also
get a lot of different facial analysis
from this service so the Lexus uh but
framework we recently launched or in
fact the aw summit two weeks ago and the
idea is you can now harness the power of
Alex or the knowledge graph of Alexa and
then now also give your own domain data
and
buying this together to have a good
experience for your customers so it
enables different both text and voice or
interactions with your customer and
there are a number of enterprise
connectors as well so just to give you a
sample example the idea is if it's about
flight booking you want to enable all
these different pieces right so if there
is a voice module that would first
recognize what the customer is saying
it's about booking the flights and then
there is the knowledge graph component
which now understands what flight means
flight booking and London means London
Heathrow right so it's now tying it to
known entities and then it's about
making the decision of what's missing
here and so asking the customer for new
information and completing this loop and
so this is how I know chatbots work and
now the question is like how should the
developer you know specify like the
working of these chat BOTS right so you
can now use the knowledge graph from
Alexa and from the Amazon domain and
combine it with your own training data
and come up with different chat BOTS so
the details are available on the website
I won't provide a lot of it and as I
said the last service we've currently
launched has been a Polly which is
real-time text-to-speech
I mean indeed like generating human-like
voices a big challenge right so there is
you know and especially if you want it
in real time and multiple languages so I
won't again give a whole lot of details
but just maybe a sample of how this
works
Ellis was beginning to get very tired of
sitting by her sister on the bank and of
having nothing to do once or twice she
had peeped into the book her sister
reading but it had no pictures or
conversations in it and what is the use
of the book God Alice without pictures
or conversations so you know there is
and that was all just generated in an
automated manner
all right so though I mean indeed there
are a lot of issues when it comes to
generating human likewise one is being
able to understand the context like here
for instance f means fan height and also
like changing the pronunciation of the
word depending on the context today in
Seattle Washington it's 11 degrees
Fahrenheit quite cold remember music
life in the Madison Square Garden so
live and life being different right so
being able to recognize that how much
weight a woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck
could shine were probably better than I
can see and the other of course as I
said depending on the context you also
want to change the pronunciation so the
fact that it's a telephone number would
change how you pronounce the numbers
richards number is two billion 120 240
1237 richards number is 2 1 2 2 3 4 1 2
3 7 yeah so so it is you know but
definitely there's a lot of research
challenges that are still are
outstanding in this area on how to have
very realistic pronunciations but poly
gets you at least some part of the way
and at the end of course at the end if
there is still pronunciations that you
are not happy with you can go ahead and
customize that my daughter's name is
Kasia my daughter's name is Kaia so you
can go and change the pronunciation at
the end and and yeah so that's um I
think mostly or what I have in terms of
you know there is a whole range of
different AI services and tools we are
developing here at Amazon right so one
is the M excellent package enabling data
scientists to run
deep learning at scale and making it
easy to launch deep learning jobs using
deep learning army and all the cloud
formation templates the other is a set
of a is enable services that allow
enterprises and large customers to
quickly get the power of AI without
having to worry about training large
models and at the same time we have a
lot of academic engagements you know my
goal is to also increase a lot of
research coming out of Amazon and we are
actively hiring and growing the team
there at the same time we have credits
available for research and for raw
education so if you have a project that
where you think it's the compute
infrastructure that's the barrier we
don't want that to be the case right so
you can apply to the grants program if
you're teaching a course and you require
credits for students to do projects
again you can apply for that here thank
you
[Applause]
so actually one person but it's a speech
synthesizer can I just think so at the
moment it's text-to-speech right so I
think click with you can combine Alexa
and then falling and you should be able
to then because with Alec so you can do
speech recognition and then I know but
currently we don't have the style
transfer yeah right now we don't I mean
by that SIA that's definitely something
that is it good to have
[Applause]